[Música]
[Aplausos]
a mí me gustaría comenzar el día de hoy
por hacerte algunas preguntas
cuanto tiempo crees que te queda de vida
mucho cuanto tiempo
70 años ok
probablemente sí probablemente más
probablemente menos
78 ok
yo quisiera
y comentarte que estamos viviendo en
esta vida
con este vehículo maravilloso que este
cuerpo humano que tenemos nosotros
es un cuerpo humano que nos permite
hablar
que nos permite pedir perdón que nos
permite decir te perdono
y nosotros estamos empacando
una maleta para irnos a la eternidad
podríamos decir que este viaje es un
viaje muy largo
podríamos decir
que si te imaginas una carretera
construida desde el polo sur hasta el
polo norte
esta vida con este cuerpo representaría
quizás el primer centímetro de esa
carretera
vamos a la eternidad
para siempre por siempre
hoy nosotros tenemos este cuerpo humano
de toda la creación el planeta tierra
podría representarse hacia el punto 0 0
0 0 1 %
y es el único planeta que conocemos
donde hay vida
y de la vida que hay en la tierra el ser
humano puede representar el punto 0 0 0
1 %
es una bendición maravillosa el tener
este cuerpo humano
porque en esta
en este viaje que vamos a emprender
tenemos que empacar en nuestra maleta
las cosas útiles que nos van a servir
para la eternidad
o qué me dirías tú o si yo te dijera yo
quiero irme a europa pero quiero
llevarlo en mi comedor y no me dejan
llevármelo porque pesa mucho
pues como que es absurdo porque tienes
el comedor
nosotros no nos queremos llevar a la
eternidad ninguna emoción negativa
ningún sentimiento negativo ningún
lastre nada que no se esté atando
queremos irnos libres queremos irnos
llenos de luz
y
queremos tener paz
esta es nuestra oportunidad
la oportunidad de tener un cuerpo humano
somos muy afortunados más afortunados
todavía porque hoy en día nosotros
vivimos con la era de la tecnología
hoy en día cuando yo era chico
imagínense nada más
en mi casa había una enciclopedia y las
familias trabajaban mucho tiempo para
lograr comprar una se creó pedja
porque la secc lo pedía era la base del
conocimiento
hoy en día en tu celular le preguntas a
google y te lo da
en el acto inmediatamente y preciso y
exacto
somos muy afortunados
pero desgraciadamente vivimos en un
mundo
en un paradigma el paradigma queriendo
decir este concepto de la realidad antes
de color la gente pensaba que la tierra
de la cuadrada y no se atrevía a ir en
barco porque el centex iban a caer
después de colom la gente dijo la tierra
redonda el paradigma es lo que la gente
cree la creencia general la creencia en
global
nosotros en el siglo 19 sucedió un
primer fenómeno que fue que la
revolución industrial convenció a la
gente del campo a irse a la ciudad les
prometió comodidades les dijo oye en
lugar de trabajar al río por ejemplo vas
a poder abrir la llave de tu regadera y
te vas al de agua caliente vas tener un
refrigerador con comida etcétera
etcétera y la gente se convenció y se
fue a la ciudad
y aparte de esto vino un nuevo paradigma
dictado por los científicos
supuestamente no en donde nos decían
la realidad es todo aquello que puedes
ver oír o tocar o comprobar a través de
uno de tus cinco sentidos físicos y de
un método de repetición
o no les dijeron esto a ustedes que eran
la realidad
luego entonces la realidad que nos
vendieron a nosotros era una realidad
materialista
en qué año vivimos nosotros
2018 porque porque vivimos en el año
2018 no en el 5000
porque hace 2000 18 años nació
jesucristo y jesucristo vino a darle un
mensaje al mundo
de amor y dijo lo único que importa en
este mundo es el amor
vino a hablar del amor
y entonces para los científicos del amor
sería real o no seas de als
para este para esta idea que nos
vendieron de que la realidad a todo lo
que puedes ver hoy de tocar
podrías tocar el amor podrías constatar
lo a través de unos otros cinco sentidos
físicos
en el momento en que nosotros nos
creímos esa realidad
automáticamente inconscientemente nos
convertimos en seres finitos porque si
la realidad fuera nuestra materia al
morir nosotros se acabaría nuestra vida
estamos de acuerdo
y no se va a acabar nuestra vida es
eterna
o si crees en la reencarnación o en lo
que tú creas el común denominador de las
religiones es que hay una vida eterna
y que hay que cambiarle muy duro porque
hoy tienes la oportunidad hoy si tienes
la oportunidad mañana quién sabe
y es interesante porque nosotros vivimos
en una dualidad muy fuerte en una
dualidad en donde por un lado está el
distrés o el este es negativo y por otro
lado está el eu3 o el estrés positivo
y
tú escoges si las cosas te van a
angustiar
si las cosas se van a producir algo un
sentimiento negativo o si te va a
producir algo positivo
no es el estímulo como de viajan se lee
el doctor que inventó el término de
estrés que dijo estrés es cualquier
respuesta en específica a tu organismo
ante cualquier estímulo no es el
estímulo lo que va a marcar que tú te
estreses o no y nosotros tenemos para
hacerlo rápido porque esto nos puede
extender muchísimo tenemos dentro de
nosotros dos fuentes de pensamiento a
veces pensamos que nosotros somos
nuestro pensamiento nosotros no somos
nuestro pensamiento nuestro paul en
nuestro proceso pensante es un proceso
pensante como el de una computadora ok y
tú tienes dos fuentes principales de
pensamiento la de tu naturaleza divina
la de tu dios
y de tu demonio interno la sombra que te
va a tratar de meter el pie que va a
tratar de meterte a la angustia que te
va a tratar de meter miedo tensión duda
incertidumbre etcétera etcétera
y tú eres la única el único que puedes
determinar en tu vida como la quieres
vivir si la quieres vivir de acuerdo a
la voz de tu dios de acuerdo a la voz de
tu naturaleza divina o si vas a escuchar
a esta sombra
para mí es muy importante
que nosotros tengamos una meta clara
si tú vas a valle de bravo y ver los
veleros en el lago te vas a dar cuenta
que hay veleros hay belenistas que van
dejando una línea una estela recta
porque saben perfectamente a dónde van y
dónde bordar y hay otros veleros que van
como a la deriva se los va llevando el
viento
tú
a dónde quieres llevar tu vida
tú sabes a dónde quieres llegar
tienes perfectamente definida dos con
absoluta claridad las metas a dónde
quieres llegar a llegar en tu vida
pero lo más importante es nosotros los
empresarios en nuestro mundo empresarios
no concebimos dirigir una empresa si no
tenemos un plan de negocios tenemos que
tener un plan de negocios pero hay muy
pocos empresarios que tienen un plan de
vida
si planean las empresas a donde quieren
que lleguen pero no planeamos quienes
queremos ser
entonces yo tuve la suerte de escribir
un libro hace más de 30 años se llama
ser hacer y tener es un libro que te
pide que te imagines que te quedan 30
días de vida nada más 30 días de vida
que te vas a morir
y que asumas que te quedan 30 días de
vida y entonces te va a ser unas
preguntas que tienes que responder por
escrito para que tu alma se puede
expresar unas preguntas como qué vas a
hacer con cada uno de estos 30 y 17
quedan de vida porque en ese en esas
cosas que vas a querer hacer está el
secreto de tu misión de vida
en esas cosas que te estás enfrentando a
la eternidad y quieres cambiar son las
cosas que les tienes que dar importancia
en tu vida
se trata entonces de enfrentarnos a
nuestra muerte porque porque
enfrentarnos a nuestra muerte porque
mira yo no he conocido a ningún enfermo
terminal que se ha salvado
que el encuentro con la muerte no le
haya cambiado la vida por completo
te puedo asegurar que las gentes que tú
conoces que se salvaron de una
enfermedad terminal nunca volvieron a
ser los mismos jamás
y los que se murieron también les cambió
la vida para siempre nada más se
murieron
entonces él confrontada tu muerte el
enfrentarte a tu muerte y él contestará
las preguntas como qué va a hacer con tu
familia qué va a hacer con tus cosas qué
vas a hacer con las cosas que faltan
cómo está tu alma en qué estado está tu
alma cómo te la vas a llevar es muy
importante porque entre más tiempo le
dedicas a los eventos a planear un
evento
mejor te sale el evento o no es cierto
y entre más importante es el evento de
tu vida más tiempo le dedicas a
planearlo no planeas igual
tu fiesta de cumpleaños de tu boda o si
dedicas el mismo tiempo
cuál es el evento más importante de tu
vida
cuál crees tú que es el evento más
importante de tu vida
el nacimiento después del nacimiento
y más importante que tu cumpleaños
tu muerte tu muerte
no por qué
son importantes pero tu alma es más
importante todavía
claro
claro claro nada más nada más que cada
uno de nosotros traemos nuestros hijos
al mundo y como sea gibrán jalil
nosotros somos los arcos y ellas son las
flechas nosotros apuntamos damos impulso
soltamos la flecha y los dejamos ir ya
su responsabilidad y ahora me queda la
mía
el momento más importante de tu vida
después de tu nacimiento es tu muerte
no hay más
y tristemente todos pensamos que nos
queda mucho tiempo para morirnos pero no
sabemos cuánto tiempo después morir
mañana
si me explico
entonces el libro lo que te plantea es
que hagas una reflexión profunda que te
enfrentes a tu muerte para que aprenda
la lección que te enfrentes con salud a
tu muerte para que aprendan la lección
que te va a dar tu muerte es una lección
muy importante que te va a cambiar la
vida por completo te lo aseguro
y después te queden todavía muchos años
más de vida para aplicar la lección en
una más te mueras y ya
si me explico y una vez que ya
encontraste
tú vamos a decir ya aprendiste la
lección que te va a la muerte entonces
se trata de que encuentres cuál es tu
misión de vida todos nosotros venimos a
este mundo para cumplir una misión de
servicio en el mundo una vocación de
servicio en el mundo y desgraciadamente
en las escuelas en todos nuestros
colegios nos preparan principalmente
para poder hacer una vida económicamente
activa y salir adelante y ganar dinero o
me equivoco
cuantos cursos por ejemplo si si la
imaginación es la facultad que marca el
progreso de la humanidad tú me puedes
describir algún objeto que haya sido
creado por el hombre que no haya sido
previamente imaginado por él
todos los objetos que conoces hechos por
el hombre fueron imaginadas por él
cuantas materias has llevado de
imaginación en tu vida
cuántos años es cursado de la materia de
imaginación
no nos prepara en los colegios para
realmente ser quienes queremos ser nos
preparar para tener lo que queremos
tener
pero lo importante no es tener
lo importante ser porque el ser es lo
que te vas a llevar a la eternidad lo
demás se va a quedar aquí y va a ser muy
triste que hayas dado tu vida por lograr
bienes materiales que a la hora de la
hora no te puedes llevar
entonces se trata de que descubras cuál
es tu misión de vida todos tenemos una
misión de vida
y dentro de esa misión de vida se trata
de que tú la puedas llegar a convertir
en tu modus vivendi
puedes llegar a ganar dinero de esa
misión no sé me explico
yo por ejemplo afortunadamente no
necesito tocar las regalías de mis
libros
las utilidades que podemos sacar de un
seminario porque afortunadamente tengo
otras fuentes de ingresos
pero deberías algo malo en que alguien
como el doctor chopra por ejemplo sea un
millonario porque ha ayudado a mucha
gente venden sus libros
qué maravilla no
yo te garantizo que si tú encuentras una
fórmula de ayudar a los demás y hacerlos
crecer
y si puedes convertir esta actividad en
algo que te remunere a ti
tu vida va a cambiar y va a ser
infinitamente más feliz a ti para ti
mismo y para los demás
creo que es bien importante que nosotros
tengamos esta visión de la misión que
tenemos que cumplir y que la podamos
hacer nuestro modus vivendi que podamos
continuar viviendo de ahí para el resto
de nuestra vida
he tenido la fortuna enorme de que
nuestros seminarios renacer damos
seminarios cada tres cuatro meses en el
santuario en valle de bravo él tiene una
fortuna enorme de que han llegado
agentes que han estudiado contabilidad y
tal vez llevaban 25 años en la
contabilidad
y de repente buscamos la misión en
cuanto a su misión y los deseos que a mí
me gusta mucho ayudar a la gente
platicar con la gente etcétera etcétera
y precioso y si te conversé terapeuta
por ejemplo pues podría ser y se
convierten en terapeuta y acaban ganando
mucho más dinero que siendo contadores
por ejemplo
no con esto quiero decir que esté mal el
dedicarse a una profesión x lo
importante es que le des un sentido a
esa profesión para que realmente tu
principal interés sea de servicio antes
que ganar el dinero no sé si hasta aquí
vamos a llamarlo entonces yo con esto
quiero dejarles este pequeño mensaje
creo que lo más maravilloso en la vida
es poder encontrar tu misión cuál es tu
misión de vida
y poder hacer de esta misión de vida tu
modus vivendi y que realmente la gente
te conozca por esta misión y que al
partido de este mundo deje una huella
una huella de amor una huella de
servicio a la humanidad y que lo que te
lleves sea algo que realmente te puedes
llevar en tu maleta de la eternidad y no
se tenga que quedar aquí muchísimas
gracias a todos
[Aplausos]